there's many people to thank you for
coming through my security who know I
lived through the war the hostage crisis
with the old mentor I had to wait how's
it any an estate is in the books
she out of her stuff in her stuff right
here and was getting her master's or MFA
here and I will be happy to say that no
one is mistake give her a job she needs
a job but I got the to Paul's mainly to
thank because the books are sometimes
the wardens their activity and that's
what happened with loss deduction paul
asked me in 2008 to give a talk on
France at the New York Public Library
and it was the occasion of the year and
well you know I could talk about
they had to talk about France returning
to the military NATO but I didn't want
to worry audience so you know what
everybody really wants to know about
Mary it just marry her the president for
a year and yet he was considered the
worst president the least likable
president in all of history
and I argue at that point well doesn't
like he doesn't entertain the French we
use the word seduce so another call who
is here tonight although who was the
editor on my right hook came up to me
afterwards
lay your next book so I gave you to
office today
the idea so I embarked on a project that
would help explain France to American
readers through the prism of seduction
and I argue to the discussion is Frances
unofficial ideology that you need aboard
our powerful engine in the bedroom
obviously but they're also powerful in
the corridors of power in diplomatic
negotiations culture and dress in
literature and matters and I had a pen
with Elvis and I said Oh
636 hits in three months just on the
word seduction and we learned that
seduction in the word is used to the
very different way and
English
I'm sorry suction in the nearest places
but there was a headline any bit Houston
or one day about Afghanistan and it had
a soldier they're all dressed up in full
battle years or through best
one morning I'm drinking coffee with my
husband and I look at the coffee
how can you work and have a debate
easier it's all about desire I said well
you know we have chock-full of my
favorite what there's a street of a road
that goes from Paris to come yet and
there was a shop and a sign Otto
turns out it was a novel and its website
said that if you can only one objective
your movement about my project probably
but she did two years to still go
topless the resources to dancer and so
is that what you don't tell me about you
know seduction and he said well it's
easy
seduction is war
it wasn't so you know where the what are
some of the where's some of the weapons
and she said
never I never knew
I already said no never accept what I'm
into that
I went to call on the Mentalist lon
yes now the face aging basically out and
she's like the perfect person
and she some very concrete advice she
said what this is a very serious subject
and you're a very serious journalist and
the only way to do it
experience so you have to have a much
lower so I said but you know I I'm
married and I really love my husband
married woman it's not gonna threaten
the guys marriage and he's not gonna
stay in France forever and believe this
is perfect
and then she gave me some advice well
the first thing is to go buy a new
wardrobe and you never go get a new
hairdo and then edit Turkish back to go
feel some pleasure and just go sit in
the café
Oh
my pretend French lovers what okay maybe
the guy downstairs is retired whereas a
cashmere smart but two ejected - right
maybe this you know radio host to is
safely gay and that had a British
colleague who offered to play the part
but especially
what are you doing this isn't one
writing down
my potential over my research for my
book different potential candidates
so I learned all sorts of things along
the ways even Paul mentioned smile
we're doing five thousand this year away
are they all right
it's really a visual correctly
or the smile a smile at strangers I had
no idea why but I was but my beloved
so in others led by French politics to
the French politicians love and our love
is the only way they can
we'll do it
you know I seriously read
she started saying that works and
reading is network I learned that when
he was on the campaign trail
women's vote knew how to do it because
he said we looked into the eyes
there's doughnuts Joe spot and every
time the dinner party would get all
right I say say Oh what about Dobies
respond what do you think about all
these stories about is a border and are
they all
and it would all be started lightly
would liven up the conversation again
you know and and most people said that
his his robust activity with bad to his
appeal though this was pretty so
detailed
but at 100 I asked
say
okay one woman said that his reputation
as sexually vigorous would add to not
detract from the bills candidate and a
male guest suggested it was a
statistical issue on the street as
quoted said the victims and friends not
the politicians who have had plenty of
women win elections this is not a
question of nature
it's a question of decree between one
and five there's no difference between
five and a thousand there would be a
difference now I get it
you know it's okay for president five
mistresses
not even trade
I'm often asked what the reaction is to
the barber and the reaction was was
quite big reaction trends on the one
hand because I was staying pretty she's
not dead the French label Tara came up
it develops their maturity said that
this was the last Odyssey
branded the book a superficial
examination of the French elite and said
the majority of people interviewed
belonged to the French go to bourgeoisie
of a certain age between fifty and then
there was American reaction
and one of the women who was part of
this group told me the story of her
broken dishwasher and the dishwasher
repairman now she had a problem because
came to the house one day and told her
that
the dishwasher needed to be replaced and
said I can prepare it right about it
will take six months and every six
months they will
the problem was her husband's company
would only pay for the repair machine
so she decided
then she dressed
more mascara so she can cook it live
look out
and we know it was a special day answer
and she needs the conversation
so then she further I just said
anyway
selling machine
so this is to me a perfect example of
how to know is never plans and how all
that seduction is is a conversation that
you've opened by finding common ground
with each other
easy
it wasn't that it would be possible to
get around and some implications of that
for crafts of this harmonized culture in
the world that is
let's talk about what happens when
you've got really nice kitchen cabinets
and you're giving the department what
happened
yes Apollo's coming up with story that
when we when my husband and I moved from
a fancy apartment the seventh of IV smog
to older more charming and much less
expensive apartment the night not long
we left behind is fabulous no you have
to put in the attention when we moved in
the kitchen was there and we bought the
kitchen this was a great kitchen this
wasn't a great cabinets Bosch appliances
and we just thought you know what
we need to save the kitchen we didn't
even necessarily want the money back we
just wanted to save the kitchen for the
next
and everything that I argued
they argued I argued that it would add
to the appeal the apartment to have
matches
I argued that that you know that we
believe they should do it because it
never was in the least that there was a
kitchen I mean I have every single egg
but you know what I realized my but I
might miss Peregrine's Bible but you had
to be like there's no room the kitchen
have and then they charged us two
thousand euros because the apartment
lease had said that was just distinct so
they worked out the whole kitchen they
put in a new sink and they charged
that is my temple anti seduction and yes
it is this incredible opportunity and
the lack of imagination I would say that
has June the French economy and so far
his residence
questions from the audience into the
seduction part yes some years ago I
another distinguished person rapidly and
it was partly by Gallup method to
support his work and his name is at each
time sauce some of you may know
he wrote in English into French and
Russian on a staggered apology
dynamo decays and when he talks he talks
for hours and the trickiness this very
evening was to be brief and why would
the Gentile witness because the minister
yes he couldn't comment because
so that's why was the right way I said
both so the question I asked him but I'm
going to ask you a very common anyway
he questions what's the meaning of life
that hasn't changed over time so what's
the meaning of not seduction but
seduction others all said that has it
changed over time because when I read
this book it sounded so much like
because there's so much of a artifice of
cunning of planning of poverty all these
various things about how my skin show
and it's all there in a different kind
of way and it also reminds you of the
fact that Louie the 16th was one of the
only kings of artistic we didn't have an
official mistress and how much that
worked against
his great-grandfather of his
great-great-grandfather who the
four-team had lost that did him a lot of
good in terms of wisdom
there is a tradition of precedence
relationships but so there's a there's a
century-old tradition of seduction but
then suddenly just why don't you book
came out this was there was this
incredible provocations dominique
strauss college where it wasn't
seduction it was it had all the
appearances and
ravers mother had encouraged me quietly
this moment
partying but you can have it
a remarkable tradition what kind of
question but did it hit the wall with
dsk did I choose change in any way
the answers were they have been more
questioning about how seduction is it
play such a role
Affairs and mysticism will be the same
the world if you were raising so many
issues that issue always do and if I
were to write this book over again the
book came out three weeks after
yeah I had Manas picture book and I
would mentioned to be in the book
because I was always considered this
puritanical American feminist
but I would argue that I would write it
exactly the same way
because predatory behavior is not
seduction next the bottom line he was
not weakened they have been seductive
but but there is no evidence that it was
more than that
predator and I found what what important
woman is let me show okay the former
head of the Socialist Party is former
prime minister said
summers
illness and that he cannot control his
impulses
Paige if someone in distress find
political
she's so clear saying this is outside
the norm was a transformer Terry Coleman
and and I would argue that that scandal
was with Springs as an immediate moment
it was a conversation the conversation
changed and in issues like rape
and incest back and sexual harassment
that before could be considered
it started changing because it opened a
conversation as in his society and
transformed now whatever there are
discussions now about what is sexual
harassment one person will be harassment
and this is why I are driving around in
this group is called its shanty much
programmers 200 of the women movers and
shakers of Frank's the women the bankers
they're politicians their Senators
incorporation future
and I interviewed a lot of people didn't
want the poll of them and I was stunned
that what I considered every behavior in
the workplace so many of them said was
just normal and that they quite enjoyed
the kind of flirtatious for a party that
in my husband's law firm in the United
States would be absolutely it's a
totally different cultural it's why
should L firm that who does does sexual
harassment training for people coming to
the United States
yeah
know what remains a lot of us undecided
was so many problems of establishments
shot long cultural attitudes as
the same thing and part of I did the
talk of the perp walk
without time to go time but still there
was denial at very high levels of
society in the beginning but after
obsessed activities with busted alleged
prostitutes but you couldn't tell is
everybody from identities home
boy
it's very complicated and it's still
played out but I still would argue that
the notion of seduction being a key to
understanding the France and all this
different aspects is something that came
as a surprise to me like I've been put
over
I thought those service before but my
wife Judith and I have experienced some
years ago I was working on a book
a flag in the 16th and there's a child
present is part of the network we used
to go and we were there we should go to
and there was this really handsome
and he was just
the game and the process and let's
domingre and let's take things let's let
things go on as long as possible whether
it's a conversation
deadlines
the car does this is not for safety in
the French Oh God
corporate has were thing
not going to work and because we can't
function here in France
we are now I know what I heard
which is better for all but someone told
me well it's not really about going to
the Delta the trick is that Belgian
citizens you
without they taxes would be good Monaco
for granted
but you know one of the people every man
I knew and I never really understood
exactly why I invited myself once I once
I've been seduction lineman and she was
one of the great reintroduces she even
though it was all about putting them
together
looking at the eye making you like her
in in strategic different kinds of ways
and I knew that there was something
there but it wasn't
a witness to have tea with her I was at
the library and I didn't popular just a
little in the history education and I
came out of that place in the mindset
about
so the library of course and everyone
was there to beginning had polar system
of a date book with photographs of women
-
way
with dogs but you talk here about
women's to do some of it would be not in
a central kind of way but you know we've
been asking you with your perfume
or engineering
we don't that asserted the aesthetic
reason but she doesn't mean that you
should wear lingerie for yourself
launch break it on that no matter what
you get my ovaries you're not going to
feel you
I said well what kind of lingerie to do
you wear she said I mean now I said yeah
and she took this black trailer which is
dressed up to here in black and she
would hold it down and there was this
- promotion goes and she was a real
guide for me Wow
at the same time really really helped me
a lot and as you guys know each other
she sent me an email late one night
saying what perfume I asked
she wouldn't know
what about it I mean what what you deal
the world did you deal with the era's
rather than people so it's worthless
paper exactly yes that's right and I had
to make well actually I did some
research but it was hard because it was
I it was a very first time to lose
Malcolm gay
we actually went to an a-hole not going
to every cool gay club in about a day
but I realized that it was maybe another
book at some point that what is
seductive for gay man Paris is America
and there were all of these films and
men and
you know videos and it was not like guys
washing cars
they were but some of the same
techniques are are married warts on the
same tools the look on the retirement
that you say everything with a look what
you can deny the look no I can look at
you but then after
which comes across as a as a toilet
seduction
these this is something that I learned
from
one of the reasons that
people were perfect men as well as
because it is a custom to the top
Moochie the double check the two
cheapest
instead of a handshake they're entering
into somebody specific
therefore one way to enter is basically
come out and so you leave a memory
intercept under all of these different
ways
a industry
what about well no assimilation it was
and it's like
the participation of people without
consent in higher education
getting jobs
as I was working class than how much the
both of these behaviors
that you described how much of this is
how does the segregated them up into
certain classes and leaves the rest of
France really engaged this is the
biggest challenge I had booked know how
to deal with how to deal with 10% of the
population the majority which probably
doesn't feel French and you know I had
spent a lot of time in the suburbs
during the riots in 2005 and I can tell
you there was very little seduction
there and I had to make choices and I
had to say okay this is a book that
explains a key a key to understanding
France not
but there is one area where I found a
universal seduction and that is
and there's a fabulous markets and
where this is you know
the Upper East Side kind of
this is every weird cultural ethnic
conviction can imagine coming together
to buy the weirdest types of looking
fish with no coconuts and your tripe
intestines
whatever
and and it struck me that even now with
the financial crisis with terrible
problems in France
jobs unemployment more than 10% with the
alienation
everybody was coming out on Sunday
morning to buy food to put on the table
and to share
that is something that whole process is
something that is that I would say it
was a way that I thought I could
but is it a problem
well when when you got your post into
France this conversation
do you add these that restarts when he
said you know what are the big issues
when you
okay